[Música]
y nuevamente actualizamos toda la
economía por supuesto con quien más sino
con daniela hablando andan y vamos a
hablar de eeuu porque tuvo un
crecimiento negativo en el primer
trimestre que está pasando en eeuu así
errado el noticia calientica como las
que les gustan a usted se contrajo en 1
4% frente al mismo período del año
pasado la economía de eeuu es la primera
vez que cae desde que entró en recesión
por la pandemia hace dos años el
crecimiento del primer trimestre se vio
obstaculizado principalmente raúl por
una menor tasa de reposición de
mercancías en las tiendas y en los
almacenes y también por una fuerte caída
de las exportaciones para 2021 en su
conjunto recordemos la economía
estadounidense había crecido un 5 7 por
ciento esto era su expansión más alta en
un año desde
1984 como efecto rebote después de la
caída del 2020
así es le quiero preguntar es que
precisamente antes que antes que
continuamos o sea yo sí que siempre le
echo la culpa a la guerra pero tengo que
meterla por supuesto es culpa de la
guerra tiene que ver con la guerra pues
miren abuela hay que hacer una
aclaración y es que la guerra empezó a
finales de febrero y eso quiere decir
que su impacto fue de poco más de un mes
en todo el trimestre que va de enero
hasta marzo en especial es lo que tiene
que ver con la inflación que ha estado
jalonada por los altos precios de los
combustibles y también por los alimentos
así que en el segundo trimestre es
cuando se va a ver más el golpe así es
bueno va a ser peor entonces según como
todo lo indica y usted que no se
equivoca con eso nos quedamos en eeuu a
ni para hablar también de las
consecuencias económicas ahora sí
netamente de la guerra claro seguimos
con nuestra serie especial sobre el tema
desde marzo se prohibió la importación
de productos estrella rusos desde
entonces reconocidas y lujosas marcas
han cerrado sus puertas a los bienes de
consumo de este país los negocios están
temiendo por una eventual escasez futura
de algunos productos nuestra
corresponsal mamen sala nos cuenta más
desde nueva york
[Música]
marisa es experta en diamantes
lleva más de 20 años al frente de este
negocio
los anillos de diamantes los hacemos
aquí pero el diamante viene de canadá o
áfrica y sabe por dónde ha llegado su
producto al país pero imposible
descubrir de dónde han sido extraídos
los minerales la teoría es que rusia
podría estar usando una tercera nación
para introducir sus piedras preciosas en
eeuu luego de la prohibición que hiciera
joe biden a los productos rusos después
del ataque a ucrania
este país de entrada podría ser un día
donde se pulen y cortan el 95% de los
diamantes del mundo
no sé exactamente de dónde vienen pero
sí sé que son 100% diamantes en una
situación similar se espera que ocurra
con el pescado y el marisco rusos que
entrará en este país a través de china
para que se haga una idea el año pasado
según la comisión de comercio
internacional el 50 por ciento del
cangrejo rojo importado a eeuu procedía
de china pero fue capturado en rusia en
el 2021 eeuu importó productos
extranjeros por valor de más
283 mil millones de dólares de los
cuales 3000 millones procedían de rusia
alrededor de un 11% como estas patas de
cangrejo paul como uno de los mariscos
más populares que llegan de rusia eeuu
este tipo de cangrejos siempre llega a
congelado gracias a que se distribuyen
congeladas todavía hay existencias pero
poco van a durar pocos los proveedores
locales tienen mucho inventario que
viene congelado por lo que por ahora no
hay problemas para conseguir el producto
pero seguimos preguntando qué va a pasar
y nadie tiene una respuesta en ese
momento le tiene claro que en sus
estanterías no habrá productos rusos
infiltrados
y no está disponible no podemos ir a la
fábrica y hacer más tenemos que lidiar
con ello una falta de producto que
impactará directamente en el bolsillo
del cliente en todos los sectores ahora
con la prohibición de entrada de
diamantes rusos los precios pueden
aumentar aún más sólo por la demanda
wang yimei son los efectos de una guerra
que aunque está a miles de kilómetros de
distancia afecta a todo el mundo
incluyendo a las propias exportaciones
rusas
afecta a todo el mundo danny los países
euro buscan mantener maneras de pagar
por el gas ruso sin incumplir sanciones
pero la advertencia de la comisión
europea fue muy clara y es que si los
países pagan en rublos por el gas
natural estarían infringiendo las
sanciones de occidente después de que
rusia cortara efectivamente el
suministro de gas a bulgaria y apolonia
a otros países ya están comenzando a
pensar será que sigo pagando en euros y
me arriesgo a un corte o será que pago
en rublos y le respondo directamente al
bloque europeo alemania dice que sigue
cancelando en euros italia dice lo mismo
y grecia asegura que ya encontrará la
manera de pagar en mayo cuando le toque
pagar en europa de todas maneras se
sigue hablando de un chantaje energético
ruso bueno danny gracias entonces como
siempre por toda la información
económica hoy jueves mañana último día
de la semana por supuesto más economía
en directo américa nos vamos directo
hasta parís